moi je n'intéresse
personne j'intéresse seulement ma
famille ma
fille mon épouse ma
[Musique]
mèreér personne
d'autre ce sont les doyens des otages de
Colombie 27 militair Captur il y a plus
de 5 par les
gu deuis dans leur prison
ver le jier c'est
lui chef militaire des phes l'homme le
plus recherché de Colombie pour les
besoins de la caméra il a accepté de
visiter ses prisonniers militaires et
civils et même d'écouter leur
doléance à propos des chaînes c'est
emmerdant vous nous enchaînez avec de
cadenas et pour marcher c'est une
galère si le premier tombe on se casse
tous la
gueule vous avez été à la hauteur ce
n'est pas un problème de mauvais
comportement pour nous c'est un problème
de
sécurité nous avons S un peu exagéré
donc j'étudierai d'autres solutions mais
pour l'heure on ne change rien on
améliorera peut-être
après j'ai un problème d'infection
rénale et aussi au colon j'ai une grosse
boule dans l'estomac
alors alors vous allez me laisser mourir
que pensez-vous faire de
moi autre chose non
non nous n'allons pas bien commandant
ici il y a des infections rénales
il y a des gens qui deviennent fous nous
avons toutes sortes de problèmes
commandant la seule chose que je veux
vous dire c'est qu'il y a 2 ans j'ai été
enlevé avec mes deux
enfantsimme an et dem on nous a
séparé je vous en suppli accordez-moi un
rendez-vous pour me parler de mes
enfants Ren de plus s'il vous plaît
merci
[Musique]
beaucoup 1830 nuit dans la jungle 100%
d'humidité sans compter les morur
venimeus ils sont au bout du
rouleau ri perdu de
combtivité je sais que ce que je vais
dire sera difficile entendre par ma
famille c'est pour
moi pour la pai en Colombie nous devons
agir en fonction de nos principes et non
de notre seul intérêt je souhaite que
l'armée tente militairement de me sauver
défintivement oui
parpe c qui est en char des opération
militair de sauvage des es
c'est se femme ministre de la Défense
dans un pays en
guerre combien de
non non c'est horrible tout ceci me
paraî horrible pour notre institution
c'est très mauvais pour les forces
armé parfait merci général à
bientôt bne mauaise nouvelle une bonne
et une mauvaise la mauvaise nouvelle
c'est un nouvel attent de la GU qui a
fait la
bonneour en
VI s'oppose toujours à une opération de
l'armée pour la libérer dans un capareil
écoutez-vous la voix des
famillest totalement et nous les avons
déjà écouté en septembre l'an dernier
nous avons reçu une information précise
sur le lieu où apparemment était retenu
ingen B en cour et
claraas dès ce moment-là mes
instructions ont été de renforcer le
travail de renseignement autour du
campement
nos soldats ont aussitôt cerné l'endroit
mais en prenant soin de rester à 2 km du
site où selon nos informations se trouva
une
Gride dans le même temps immédiatement
nous avons prévenu la famille elle nous
a demandé de nous abstenir de tenter une
opération j'ai respecté le désir de la
famille j'ai aussitôt donné l'ordre de
tout
annuler' des maisinv la moindre parcelle
du territoire colombien Puerto asis
département du Pouillot le sanctuaire
des FAR ce jour-là pourtant le président
et sa ministre n'ont pas hésité à venir
défier la Guer sur son terrain le
Président c'est l'homme au chapeau ne
pas se fier aux apparences il a survécu
à une vingtaine d'attentat sans jamais
s'émouvoir nous arrivons très tard la
visite sera deux fois plus courte que
prévu c'est à cause de la pluie oui oui
ou le temps n'était pas bon nous avons
dû nous poser à M il n'y a pas que la
pluie à cet instant le général
commandant les forces armées les informe
des vraies raisons de leur retard un
nouvel attentat qui les visé près de
l'aéroport briefing AUG du général
Pineda commandant la 47e brigade de
jungle ce matin vous avez été détourné à
via Garson près de mokoa la capitale du
département le pu de pétrole dynamité
par la guerria se trouve dans ce secteur
là nous avons toute une zone importante
Puerto
nuevo la Guera a effectué à cet endroit
ce que j'appelle un regroupement d'après
nos renseignements c'est là que se cach
plusieurs chefs de guerriéros avec leur
famille vous savez ils ont be se replier
nos soldats iront les chercher là où ils
sont et ils vont les débusquer
n' qu'un crédau une guerre totale contre
ce qu'elle baptise la
narcogeria para la
coca todo eso fue para la
[Musique]
coca yo también quiero saber qué más
cosas podemos hacer nosotros para
ayudarles para que los resultados Sean
mejores y si usted por ejemplo se monan
a las capturas masivas tiene que
organizar un buen trabajo de intelencia
está necesitando una platita Med Ayudo a
conseguir una Plata de recompens des
moyens toujours plus considérables car
la guerria n'a rien perdu de son pouvoir
de nuisance il y a un mois ils ont
dynamité ce puit de pétrole on vient
tout juste de
l'éteindre la visite d'une ministre de
la Défense au fin fond de cette jungle
ce n'est pas tous les jours les soldats
en profite pour faire passer un message
à leur famille sur un billet de banque
vous avez eu des combats importants ici
oui il y a 8 jours cétait tout près
d'ici dur vraiment dur le problème c'est
que nous sommes sur la zone frontalière
les guos passent de l'autre côté
facilement je sais il se réfugi en
Équateur et il se mett en civil pour
passer
inaperçu je vous apporté des petits
cadeaux merci pour votre travail Dieu
vous bénisse tous
courage qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans ces
paquets des serviettes des affaires de
toilett des t-shirts des sous-vêtements
c'est ce qui est nécessaire pour tenir
dans la jungle bien sûr il sont là
depuis un
mois on se dit bon on a passé de 6 ans
ici c'est comme si on avait été enlevé
hier peut-être que pour vous ça n'
aucune
importancezv faire de nous on va rester
ici toute la
vie préparezv à rester ici longtemps
personnellement je pense qu'avec ce
gouvernement il n'y a pas de solution
nous ne parviendrons pas un accord
humanitaire on a fixé nos
conditions
leurs condition le gouvernement
colombien les rejette à l'image de son
principal sponsor les États-Unis à
l'instant de quitter le pu dynamité un
ingénieur s'approche de l'hélicoptère
c'est un
[Musique]
américain avec le président pour un
simple ingénieur il est vrai qu'avecé
les Américains se sentent un peu chez
eux en Colombie ils ne font pas qui jou
les pompiers volants à Bogota ce jourl
la ministre de la Défense attend la
visite d'un invité prestigieux c'est le
premier voyage de Donald runfeld
enamérique du Sud et ce n'est pas un
hasard si le secrétaire à la Défense
américain a choisi la
[Musique]
Colombie
45 minutes de conférence de presse pas
un mot sur les otages sujet
[Musique]
tou moi je n'intéresse
personne j'intéresse seulement ma
famille ma fille mon épouse ma
mère
moi n'intéresse personne
d'autre 2,5 milliard d'aide américaines
en 3 ans sans cette man la guerre totale
imaginée par Marta lu Ramirez serait
inabordable pour la Colombie cela vaut
bien de se lever à l'au pour accompagner
son
hôte sur le chemin du retour madame la
ministre est soudain en veine de
confidence elle aborde d'elle-même
l'épisode recomolesque du sauvetage
inrid par un avion militaire français en
juillet dernier la Guera piège tout le
monde c'est g des
FAR vous croyez à un
piège oui nous pensons que oui
ils ont envoyé un message annonçant sa
libération à travers un paysan qui a
pris contact avec le
gouvernement ce qui n'est pas très clair
c'est'ils avaient prévu un
échange sortir de Colombie mal nous
saons pas avec
exactitude qui est S c'est que ça ét
fiasco au
français à mes côté malgré la distance
merci comment le gouvernement colombien
a-til vécu cet
épisode vous savez pour le gouvernement
quand c'est une libération sans
condition que ce soit une Gride ou tout
autre Tage c'est toujours
bienvenu une libération spontanée
personne NRO en Colombie et surtout pas
les otages qui ne compte pas plus sur la
bonne volonté du
gouvernement
nous ne pouvons pas susciter l'intérêt
du gouvernement commandant
mono parce que ni moi ni aucun des
politiques ici présents n'appuyons le
président pour des raisons évidentes
d'opposition
politique nous ne partageons pas la
tendance qu'
l'incarne nous n'éveillons en lui aucune
sympathie je voulais d'ailleurs signaler
ce problème ainsi qu'au secrétariat
général des FARC pour qu'on étudie des
alternatives moi je crois qu'un échange
humanitaire est possible notamment grâce
à l'intérêt qu'on manifesté les Nations
Unies c'est pour obtenir cet échange
humanitaire entre age et guéréros
emprisonnés que chaque mardi les
familles des kidnappés manifeste sur la
place Bolivard la terreur des familles
c'est une opération de sauvetage par
l'armée qui tourne mal comme au mois de
mai dernier 10otage exécuté par les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Fes de nous disuader de tenter de sauver
les
otages nous ne pouvons évidemment pas
accepter ce type de
[Musique]
chantage après les 10 morts lâchement
assassiné d'A nous avons continué à
procéder à des sauvetages une trentaine
au total car nous pensons que l'État ne
doit pas
vaciller ce d'entre vous qui sont
militaires savent bien que quand on a
des prisonniers la première mission est
de préserver leur vie mais la seconde
c'est que si les conditions ne sont plus
réunies on les
élimine il le fera John fr pinch au des
depuis 4 ans et 8 mois ne paraî pas en
dter Joh Aleandro je sais que tu ne me
connais pas je suis ton papa tu es né
pendant ma
captivité je sais que tu peux maintenant
me comprendre mon fils j'espère un jour
pas trop lointain pouvoir te connaître
t'écoutter et te serrer dans mes
bras et t'apportter tout ce dont je t'ai
privé à cause d'un conflit que plus tard
tu
comprendras ne plus espérer qu'une
opération militaire à haut risque pour
être libérer ce n'est pas seulement une
question de principe pour une grid c'est
aussi l'expression du désespoir